there are not actively involved in this
campaign but suppose Hillary Clinton and
not involving the nomination but she
becomes president what would be your
advice concerning the three topics we
should which he should measure top
priority as president of America well
she absolutely has to as president
because she will be commander-in-chief
and again that's different for many
countries press the United States is
commander in chief of our armed forces
and swears an oath to protect the people
and the Constitution the United States
so she will have to deal with terrorism
and with groups like Isis I mean the
that just comes with the job so I would
say that's not enough so much number one
but that's part of every day of her job
and what should be surprised about
be able to talk of the symposium maybe
about how you do that but she absolutely
is committed to do it and she's ready to
do it I think secondly she's going to
have to be much clearer about American
leadership in the world
and but what I mean is clear is that
Obama has sent lots of mixed signals and
sometimes he's talked a lot about
military force other times he's talked
about diplomacy but he kind of goes hot
and cold and sometimes he seems like he
wants to intervene in countries other
times he doesn't it's it's very I think
there's not really Obama doctrine other
than what he said don't do stupid things
but of course why should any press the
United States do stupid things people
are going to look to the United States
for leadership on a number of issues and
obvious ones climate change but we can
come back to others how to relate to
food how to deal with a rising China and
choosing big these are all challenges
that anyone who becomes president has to
deal with but i think that interesting
and most difficult challenge for mrs.
Clinton if she becomes president is how
to bring America together because as you
said Rob this is a very divisive time
read their reasons for it and we have an
angry right-wing populism supporting
Donald Trump I would argue also even
worse supporting Ted Cruz but we have a
kind of angry left wing populism
supporting Bernie Sanders and what is
there some commonality or reasons for
this anger and can she tease that out
and then come up with ideas programs and
language it starts to bring the country
together to heal a lot of these divides
I think their ideas about how to do it I
think she could do it and I think it's
going to be a big challenge but that's
really the hardest thing because it's
going to be a very bitter election and
groups like the Koch brothers are going
to spend upwards of half a billion
dollars trying to defeat her the worst
things you can imagine that have been
said about her would be repeated and
adds new things will come up and at the
end of it a lot of people are going to
be
even more bitter and angry how does she
deal with them as president